There's a different person saying I would like to try the bed design. Why not?
How much should someone like me, 89 pounds, take, and for how long? Is there anything else to be
aware of while taking it? Well, the bed design is protocol that has been widely known as the Joe
Tippen's protocol because it's a guy named Joe Tippen's who I believe had lung cancer
and he used this bed as a protocol and it got better and he's still alive today
where they had just given him weeks or months to live. So if a bed design is used not by itself,
so his protocol was to take Ben Ben. So that's what you call it for short.
Boy, come on, smell check. So you take Ben Ben and then take curcumin, take
a pop E, which is the type of E that the delta token tree and all type of E.
And then he expanded it to taking burberry as well and then also taking a CBD oil.
So that was, this is the Joe Tippen's protocol. If you just call our office, we actually have these
in packs and you could start taking it. Now, how much of the bed design does someone take?
Typically, in Joe Tippen's standard protocol of somebody who's either low weight
or their cancer is all that aggressive, you just do one packet per day. Now, the product of
bed design that we have is one packet is for a 10 pound dog. So that doesn't seem like a very high dose
because it's not. It's a very, very low dose of bed design. But he recommended
and some veterinarians that recommend this protocol and alternative doctors that recommend
this protocol is that you do up that dose dependent on weight. If you weigh 200 pounds, you probably
have to take two or three packets a day. But it also depends like if your cancer is fairly stable
and you just want to try the Tippen's protocol, you might just start with one packet a day.
If your weigh 240 pounds and your cancer is aggressive, you might take three packets a day.
The other thing about this protocol, you only do the fed bed design four days a week.
So you do the everything else every day, but you do the fed bed design four days a week. So
Monday through Thursday, you would take the fed bed, then Friday Saturday, Sunday, you would
only take these. Excuse me, Monday through Thursday, you would take all of these, and then Friday
and Saturday, Sunday, you would only take these things. So everything except the
recursion is not working. Everything except the fed bed. But again, if you have a very aggressive
cancer and you're getting worse, then your cancer is continuing to grow, then you change that
dosage. You don't really change dosage, the curcumin, apopi, burberry, and CBD, which change
the doses of the fed bed. You might take it daily. So when we test people,
full red eye tests for how many packets and how many days a week. So it's all over the board.
It does have to do with the person's weight. Body weight started off, but it has to do with that person's
aggressiveness and the cancer. And fed bed can be used really for any cancer.
I would say any cancer except typically it's not used for brain cancers.
And it's typically not used for the leukemia. So any solid tumor cancer,
minus the brain cancers, I've never had a test for anybody with brain cancer. But anybody else,
you could try it. I mean, there's really, you know, the only side effects that I've ever had
anybody say to me is that it gave a little tummy ache. And I gotta say, I was not convinced
that it was the fed bed that gave them the tummy ache. It could have been something else. The capsules
of the supplements are taken. It's how it is a powder. It comes in a little packet. You put it in a
smoothie. It really doesn't have any taste. And I remember one packet is what you'd give it 10
pound dog for helping it deworm. So it's way under dose for a human. Now, you could get the
bedbed is all, which is the human form of fed bed is all, which is really the exact same thing.
But it's much more expensive. And a lot of people would rather just get this so that they don't have
to go and get it by the doctor that's going to give them a prescription for it.